um you've just captured passenger
numbers at 100 000 per day why's that
well this is departing passenger numbers
and the reason we've done that is to
keep the demand at the airport in
balance with the capacity of the
airline's ground handlers what we've
seen over the course of this year as
we've been scaling up across the airport
we've hired 1300 people just within our
own team that's a 25 increase like
trying to get ahead of demand and we've
performed really well at both easter and
the jubilee half term but what we
started to see towards the end of june
was that demand was getting ahead of
where the airline's capacity was and
what were the way that came out was that
we started to see more cases of uh
airplanes being held off stand
late delivery of bags bags not being
taken out of the baggage system and
causing congestion and then worst of all
some planes leaving without any bags on
board and some last minute cancellations
and that was the early warning signal we
have that we had to act to cap demand in
line with the airline's ground handler
supply so that we could protect journeys
over the summer and that cap has worked
i'm in terminal five right now it's
running smoothly and we've got millions
of passengers away in the last couple of
weeks
with an untroubled journey uh and we'll
get millions of more traveling with
confidence through heathrow this summer
i'm the airline say that you should have
anticipated this increase of demand and
raised staffing capacity accordingly
well we absolutely have uh back in
november of last year we started to
increase our our capacity we have as
many people working in securities we had
before covid we got as many people
working in our wheelchair support
services as we had before covid the
issue is the ground handling staff which
are employed by the airlines has not
increased at all in the last six months
and that is what needs to change and so
many of the issues that i've had
passengers writing to me about
complaining about late delivery of bags
or
late cancellations are because of that
lack of ground handling resource and as
the airport operator we have a view of
how the whole airport system works and
we can see where the problems are and we
took the responsible action to step in
and put a cap on demand and that has
really worked to make sure that people
can travel with confidence and this is
not just a heathrow of course um all uh
airports and airlines are
struggling with the uh co to cope with
the increase in demand
half of all the people employed in
ground handling across europe left the
industry during covid and
most airlines have been struggling to
get enough people back again and i think
it will take 12 to 18 months as a
minimum before they have fully replaced
all the people that they lost during
covet uh so uh we will work with them to
support them we'll help them with the
recruitment uh we are already lending
them people to help with the baggage
system but we cannot have a situation
where people are leaving without their
bags will have a last minute
cancellation and that's why the cap is
in place and i should say actually our
cap is 50 larger than the cap at
amsterdam which is our nearest
competitor and that shows how uh
collectively uh we've done a really good
job to get ready for this but there
comes a point when we have to say enough
is enough to protect the holiday travel
plans for millions of passengers through
heathrow this summer
obviously uh bottlenecks in hiring are
partly down to people getting security
clearance is the government doing as
much as it could do in that respect
well we'd like to see them speed up with
that a lot of the ground handling roles
are very much uh sought after it's the
same people who could go and work in
amazon people with clean driving
licenses um and if you remember
not many months ago that's those driving
skills that were uh in such short supply
and i think that's where a lot of the
people who have been working in ground
handling have moved on to so the ground
handlers need to be competitive in terms
of the pay that they have the terms and
conditions to attract people in airlines
have to allow them to increase their
charges to be able to cover those
additional costs
but we also need to see a an
acceleration in um getting people
security cleared because if you've got a
job offer from amazon which starts today
and one from a ground handle that starts
in three months time when you've gone
through security clearance you're
obviously going to take the bird in the
hand um so government can help if we had
quicker access to the hmrc tax records
that would speed things along uh there's
been some progress on that but not
nearly enough to get people into the
airport quickly and that's one of the
reasons why i think it will take at
least 12 to 18 months before airlines
have enough ground handlers to meet the
demand
all right john holland good to talk to
you again this morning thanks very much
indeed thank you